Black Panther it's a world leader that's
a responsibility that other superheroes
don't commonly have that he has to look
out for an entire nation that will only
be the conquered and conquerors the door
mulashi are women who ledged their lives
to the throne and to the security of the
kingdom my character
Okoye is the general of the armed forces
as whole
Okoye represents the old guard and
tradition while my character and the kia
two challenges traditionally you get to
decide what kind of King you are going
to me Nakia was born to be a warrior she
was born with a warrior's spirit I got
into a disagreement made a bit of a mess
trainee was very very interesting the
doora have a way of fighting that was
supposed to be inspired by moving as one
the door worked together to take down
somebody like the fight
[Music]
actions there is not your typical film
it's raw it's real
don't please
hey everybody so we got a whole bunch of
new marble to talk about we got to talk
about the dorm Allah hey how badass they
are and the Black Widow movie I know
you've all been asking for a video about
that there's all kinds of stuff we can
say about that let's start with the dorm
Ellijay first because they are badass if
they mind you of a certain fighting
group of warrior women that you recently
saw in the movies that's on purpose
fighting is one a sense of choreography
that you don't see in traditional
fighters so if you're finding me for the
first time be sure to subscribe to get
everything there's also a new route of
that Infinity Gauntlet giveaway that
I'll explain at the end of the video so
purely on a story level you can see
what's going on within the door Milosh a
not all them agree with each other even
though they're totally committed to the
safety and security of Wakanda what kind
of forever is the chant that you keep
hearing in every single piece of media
that they've released like all the
different footage they have there's
always a Wakanda forever being shouted
so that's the whole idea of the movie is
that you have all these people fighting
there's this civil war going on you know
make jokes about Captain America civil
war within Wakanda what you have ulysses
klaw and erik kill monger that are
trying to take what Wakanda has and use
it to conquer the world you have this
physical battle between the old and the
new like literally the older characters
really hate what Black Panther and some
of these younger characters are doing
like no no no this is the way we've done
things for thousands of years do not let
the outside world end they would have
him abandon anything that he would do
with the Avengers so think about what
that would mean for infinity war
obviously we know that Black Panther
will become an Avenger during infinity
war so you kind of know how this is
gonna end up but the funny thing is is
the this civil war within Wakanda this
fighting amongst the tribes has always
been a thing going all the way back to
the first king of Wakanda the first
Black Panther so when they finally
united as a nation what happened is is
the dorm Elijah was formed from all the
different tribes they would go around
selecting the most badass female
fighters and they would become like the
ceremonial wives of the king of Wakanda
they would gain his ear but they would
become part of this fighting force so it
would be like all the different tribes
gaining representation because it's not
a democracy like they don't have a
Senate you don't elect people from all
the different tribes
so just because it's called Wakanda in
its one nation doesn't mean that
everybody does exactly the same things
they have some shared traditions but all
the different tribes are very different
themselves Danai gurira explains how
their fighting style is tailored to make
them stronger as a whole like they fight
in a certain synchronicity reminds you
of the Amazons from Wonder Woman it's
actually an interesting thought if the
dermal ashay were to fight the Amazons
who would win because the Amazons are
technically a little bit stronger more
naturally inclined to battle but the
Dorma lodge a have weapons that are much
more sophisticated and much stronger
like even though Wonder Woman has the
lasso of Hestia she has the sword she
has the shield the armor not all of them
have special god-blessed armor but
they're naturally much much stronger
because they were created by Zeus so
they're just a little bit faster a
little bit stronger more resilient than
normal human fighters the door Milosh a
obviously very strong because they train
a lot but they don't eat the
heart-shaped herb like Black Panther
does so they don't have the super
strength that he gains from that if a
normal person tried to start eating it
it would wind up poisoning them that's
how strong it is but moving into Black
Widow territory so they're actually
announcing a Black Widow movie is in
development they hired a writer in
Scarlett Johansson is supposed to be
meeting with her relatively soon so it
does sound like they actually intend to
make a black widow movie whether we
actually get to see it remains to be
seen biometric and behavior of puttan
scans
move or you will be moved as
entertaining as that would be the real
test like if you want to know if they
actually do plan on making a black widow
movie is as if Kevin Feige announces it
on the schedule at Comic Con like when
he unveils their phase four movies like
here the next couple of movies we're
gonna be making
we have Guardians three we have our next
spider-man movie after Avengers 4 he
said going forward they had about 20
movies that they had planned before the
Fox Disney deal had started to go
through now that that's done if it
sticks like if the government approves
it their plans might change quite a bit
because they get access to all those
x-men characters but I think it was only
a matter of time till they got to the
Black Widow movie I think Kevin Feige he
actually said something funny about the
Wonder Woman movie because he said he
totally loved it
but he also said he was a little upset
that DC beat them to that female-led
movie punch like he's like we really
like being the first to do stuff like
they were the first to do the big
superhero team-up The Avengers movie
then everybody else is scrambling to
create their Cinematic Universe but DC
did Wonder Woman and kevin buggies like
BAM you beat us on that one we'll give
you that but we're gonna get you on
everything else so I think the
floodgates have just opened on every
weird character every weird movie that
they would have never tried before the
funny thing about the Black Widow movie
is that they just dropped that Jennifer
Lawrence trailer called red Sparrow and
it's basically a black widow movie that
was the joke that was going around I
almost did a parody video for that young
officers trained to do
manipulating teaser bodies but I think
you know there's a couple clear places
that you could take an actual black
widow movie you can make the big bad the
Sophia black widow the person who's
trying to steal the mantle of Black
Widow from Natasha Romanov you could put
Winter Soldier in there you could do
flashbacks when she talks about I have a
read on my ledger you could do Red Room
flashbacks they actually showed a
version of the Red Room
on agent Carter but we got those
flashbacks during Avengers age of Ultron
so you just build that out there are a
number of different places that you
could take it but it would basically be
a spy thriller and Marvel hasn't done a
whole lot of movies like that very
different fare from what you would think
of a traditional superhero movie
Charlize Theron also just did that
atomic blonde movie with the director of
Deadpool - that's kind of like a black
widow movie so if you want to get an
idea for what that would feel like
just watch atomic blonde watch that
Jennifer Lawrence movie whenever it
comes out but the advantage that Marvel
has is that you can have her running
around the world into all the biggest
characters of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe especially if you do flashbacks
but they don't have a director they
don't have a script yet if they can get
that out by the end of the year and hire
their director then usually it's about a
two year turnaround from the moment they
hired the director unless they really
fast-track it
so I'm guessing minimum two and a half
years before we actually see this movie
if it does end up happening so just let
me know in the comments what do you
think about the idea of a black widow
movie which characters do you want to
cross over and who do you want the
villain to be like I said there was a
new Infinity Gauntlet giveaway in this
video on outs the winner in the next
Marvel video that I post but
congratulations to the winner from last
week's video Johnny Johnson reacts
please private message me so I can get
your contact details click here for that
Deadpool to prank teaser and click here
for brand new infinity war thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]